ukrainian president volody mirzalenski
has visited troops on the southern front
line while his army battles a russian
onslaught in the donbass region
ukrainian forces have also been fighting
off attempts by russia to seize more
territory near the southern cities of
nicolaive and odessa with little change
to frontline positions in recent days
the head of nato jens saltenberg says
the war could go on for years
inspecting the devastation with his own
eyes
ukraine's president vladimir zelinski on
his first tour of the southern front
in the strategic port of odessa and the
embattled city of mikalive the president
awarded medals to the soldiers and
doctors defending the front lines
his visit comes only a day after a
russian strike killed two people and
injured 20 in mecca live
despite constant russian shelling in
ukraine's south the main conflict
remains focused on the donbass in the
east
the focus of the invaders is now on the
cities of sierra donetsk and
to improve the tactical position the
enemy tried to conduct assault
operations outside the city but was
unsuccessful
over the past few months russia has
taken control of almost all of the
eastern luhansk province largely due to
an overwhelming artillery advantage
outnumbered and outgunned ukraine has
repeatedly urged the west to send
heavier weapons to the front lines
we have good weapons but we need much
better ones we need artillery that
shoots further
our technology dates back to the 80s we
take care of it often but it still gets
broken
western deliveries of heavy artillery
have taken time
but some including these us-made
howitzers are already having an impact
on the battlefield
the difference between the weapons we
had before and the new ones
this cannon is much more precise
it shoots faster and it's simple to
operate
and because it's lower to the ground
it's easier to camouflage it
as the war increasingly becomes a battle
of artillery western military supplies
are ever more critical
but for the ukrainian troops holding on
in the donbas the weapons aren't coming
fast enough
well let's go to dw correspondent
emmanuel shaz who's in kiev good to see
you emmanuel now volatility has traveled
to the southern front line for the first
time
how important is this for ukrainians to
see their president leaving the capital
well vladimir zelansky is the president
of all of ukrainians not just people
based in care for people who have
had to flee the country following this
war and he is very much proving it uh by
this visit on the southern front uh
which has been under
nearly constant shelling which has
suffered a heavy fighting and of course
heavy losses for the ukrainian army you
have to keep in mind that there's at
least 100 ukrainian soldiers maybe much
more dying on a daily
basis so i think it's quite important
that the president is coming to visit
the troops for uh to boost their morale
and also he was handing out some medals
to
to some soldiers who had been injured
but also for civilians it's important
that they don't only see their president
giving addresses from the presidential
palace post
posting his addresses on social media
it's important for ukrainians to see
that the president is very much hands-on
and is pretty pretty much on their side
because you know there's a huge
difference uh in this war uh about what
is happening in the eastern front and on
the southern front compared to places
that feel relatively safer like here in
kiev life is of course not normal
because everybody is very much aware
there's a war going on but we're not
under constant challenges just like in
other parts of the country so very
significant visit today
now nato general secretary jens
stoltenberg told a german newspaper
today that the war in ukraine could last
years how much of a blow is this for
ukrainians and is there much discussion
on what that might look like for ukraine
um what really uh struck me when i'm uh
i was talking to people here is that
they are determined to not stop fighting
until the last russian saudi will have
uh uh will have left the country that's
what mayor of italy klitschko kiev mayor
vitale klitschko was saying yesterday he
was saying well uh ukraine will only go
back at the negotiation table when the
fight uh the fighting will have ended
and when all the russian soldiers will
have would have left
ukrainians so this just shows you just
how determined uh people are you have to
keep in mind that uh ukraine didn't
you know didn't uh isn't the aggressor
in that conflict it's defending its land
it's defending its culture uh so there's
an incredible
sentiment of resilience of determination
to fight
no matter the cost unfortunately the
cost is very very high not just for
soldiers there's also
countless civilians who are dying on a
daily basis here in ukraine
emmanuel shaz in kiev thank you
you